aux centrales nucléaires la journaliste
et créatrice du balances ton port a été
condamné pour diffamation dans un tweet
publié en 2010 est à l'accusé eric brion
l'ex patron de la chaîne equidia de
harcèlement face à l'emballement
médiatique eric brion avec une véritable
descente aux enfers on vous a fait un
petit récap de l'histoire et on va tout
vous expliquer puisqu'il sera avec nous
eric brion et vous allez voir qu'il a
connu l'enfer c'est parti regardez c'est
en 2017 sur les réseaux sociaux qu un
mouvement mondial s'est opérée pour
libérer la parole des femmes et faire
connaître au plus grand nombre les
pratiques des places et de certains
hommes
popularisé sous le nom demi tour dans le
monde en france le mouvement prend une
autre appellation et opère de façon plus
frontale en dénonçant les présumés
coupables sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
la naissance de balances ton port
derrière ce mouvement se cache une femme
sandra muller journaliste française
implantée à new york c'est depuis des
états unis le 13 octobre 2010 est
qu'elle crée lance ce hashtag en
dénonçant eric brion dans un tweet
tu as des gros seins che mon type de
femme je vais faire rire toute la nuit
eric brion ex patron equidia tout de
suite le buzz au père est le mouvement
est lancé
mais si ce hashtag à libérer beaucoup de
femmes et il a aussi causé beaucoup de
dégâts chez les hommes accusé
ouvertement à raison ou à tort parmi eux
eric brion ancien patron de la chaîne
equidia et premiers roms dénoncé par le
mouvement ils déclarent avoir vécu
l'enfer après cette affaire tout de
suite sa compagne le quitte ses amis lui
tourner le dos et il ne peut plus
travailler il tombera même en dépression
face à l'emballement médiatique je suis
devenu un paria dans mon milieu
la violence absolue de ceux qui
planquait derrière leur écran vous
insulte sans que vous ne puissiez vous
défendre des conséquences qui l'ont
poussé à attaquer sandra muller dans un
procès dont le jugement a été rendu
aujourd'hui le tribunal de paris a
tranché en faveur du plaignant et a
condamné son drap muller à 15000 euros
de dommages et intérêts pour diffamation
au profit d' eric brion une condamnation
qui montre bien la complexité de ce
dossier
alors pour vous balance ton port
libération ou diffamation
les deux alors eric brion est avec nous
et merci d'être là éric mercier de me
recevoir
alors ça a démarré ce par son ballon ce
ton port c'était lors d'une soirée vous
connaissiez me sandra muller oui j'ai
cette soirée elles datent d'octobre 2012
d'octobre 2012 et à cannes c'est le
marché des programmes cela ou bien sûr
selmi puis ce qu'on appelle le mythe
donc il ya tous les producteurs de télé
et tout les patrons tienne vous êtes
patron d'equidia complètement
à l'époque je connais sandra muller
depuis une quinzaine d'années et on se
retrouve à tard vers minuit et demi dans
un cocktail est bon c'est festif on a
hautmont a bu quelques coupes de
champagne et c'est vrai que je vais je
suis un peu impressionné par sandra et
je lui dis vous êtes séduits par sandra
oui je suis je suis impressionné j'ai dû
lui dit et je les mots sont crus avec
beaucoup en fait avec un trouvait loin
moi j'ai été lourd et je lui ai dit oui
tu as des gros seins c'est mon type de
femme est là elle m'a dit stop
c'est vrai qu'on se connaît depuis
longtemps et là contrairement à ce
qu'elle a écrit j'ai jamais dit je vais
te faire jouer au tennis je suis parti
en blaguant avec de l'humour en disant
je t'aurais fait jouer toute la nuit et
puis je suis parti me coucher et le
lendemain matin j'ai envoyé un message
pour m'excuser donc ça c'était en 2012
on continue à se voir helm interviewe
d'ailleurs pour equidia on continue à se
connecter sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis cinq ans plus tard elle lance
est lancée et elle accuse eric brion de
28 à 10 tu as des gros seins tu es mon
type de femme je vais te faire rire
toute la nuit eric brion ex patron
d'equidia balance au cordeau que ça veut
dire qu'elle avait retenu ça depuis cinq
ans oui il faut dire quel est le sort un
moment un peu spécial c'est à dire cinq
jours après le début de la ferme la
sphère weinstein et voilà exactement est
d'abord elle fait un premier tweet ou
elle ne cite personne elle donne pas de
nom le tweet ne prend pas et cinq heures
plus tard elle va en faire un second
tweet ou là elle donne mon nom elle
reproduit des paroles que je conteste je
n'ai jamais dit ça comme ça et derrière
c'est un emballement complètement dingue
locales s'ils votent non hélas elle
ballon balance mon nom qu'est ce qui se
passe après je voulais essayer de
l'appeler j'ai tout de suite essayé de
l'appeler on a on a des amis en commun
ils avaient eu nom à la con
demande refusée elle a fait savoir à mes
amis qu'elle voulait pas me parler
qu'elle était partie et au début ça
prend doucement puis d'un seul coup ça
explose et la cee
je sais pas comment vous je sais pas si
des gens ont déjà vécu ça c'est
apocalyptique
je reçois des insultes de partout de
gens que je ne connais pas alors vous
êtes la halle en ce moment là parce que
c'est c'est assez fort vous êtes en
train de préparer l'anniversaire de
votre fille ouais vous êtes en train de
gonfler les ballons de l'hiver ça nous
avons fait des voiliers loin de blanc et
là tout s'écroule
mais là tout s'écroule dans en une
semaine je vais perdre toute l'émission
ma société je vais tous mes rendez vous
ce que je cherche du travail en même
temps tous mes rendez-vous sont annulés
il ya des copains qui partent
ma compagne de l'époque avec laquelle
j'étais pas du tout moment de cette
soirée le sien on était ensemble faisons
elle va pas tenir l
je peux la comprendre j'ai vraiment pris
j'ai été très très mal donc elle ça va
durer des semaines des mois je vais
faire gagner à la normale pression fait
une énorme dépression
et puis je décide voilà de porter
plainte en diffamation pourquoi parce
que parce que elle m'accuse de
harcèlement sexuel au travail
alors j'ai écouté ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure le harcèlement sexuel au
travail c'est très encadré on sait ce
que c'est mais moi j'ai jamais travaillé
avec sandra muller j'ai jamais été
jamais été sont coopérateurs jamais été
son patron et elle m'accuse de
harcèlement sexuel au travail mais de
quoi on parle donc évidemment que
c'était faux et elle a lancé balances
ton port sur quelque chose de faux sur
du sable alors ça a été très bénéfique
pour beaucoup ce que mine de rien son
drap müller il ya plein de femmes qui
peuvent aujourd'hui la remercie il
n'aura pas ce que moi je la connais un
peu son mobile art on se côtoyait avant
parce que tu vois la journée jaoui c'est
quelqu'un avec qui j'ai toujours une
très bonne relation qui est très
sympathique c'est vrai très sympathique
au tournoi comme ça les a et voilà j'ai
toujours eu de très bonnes en assurer
qu'elle est c'est vrai que moi quand
j'ai vu l'histoire
j'étais comme toutes les femmes comme et
je me suis dit ah la la pauvre voila
voila vous je sais vous êtes coup
mouvement le mouvement mitu mine de rien
aussi voilà vous et ça je sais que ça ça
vraiment ça a ruiné votre vie parce que
même vos meilleurs amis vous ont laissé
tomber il y en a qui sont partis
quelques-uns la plupart sont restés
et j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que
votre famille vos enfants comment
comment ça s'est passé le plus dur en
fait la famille c'est ce qui a tout
compliqué maintenant vous avez expliqué
à vos enfants vos enfants ils ont quel
âge j'ai une fille qui à 20 ans qui fait
ses études à l'étranger c'est la
première personne que j'ai appelé ça a
été très violent parce que il a fallu
que je explique ella ella ella compris à
la voilà c'est une jeune fille
féministes qui qui fait ses études
qu'une jeune fille brillante
conversation a été longue mais elle a
compris après il a fallu en parle à ma
mère ah ouais il a fallu j'en parle à ma
soeur pour quelque chose dont j'étais
accusé et que je n'avais pas fait
j'avais été lourd oui vous avez le
devoir cette soirée je m'en suis même
excusé publiquement dans une tribune
dans le monde mais j'ai jamais j'ai
jamais harcelé sexuellement au travail
sandra muller et mais imaginez vous à
l'époque charge de travail sous les gens
des médias connaissent bien sûr ça et
toutes les portes se ferment quand je
dis tout c'est tout il ya quelques
personnes qui vont bien mais plus
travailler depuis j'ai fait quelques
missions en ce moment j'en suis pour
mais ces nouvelles maps poste fixe non
je fais une mission en ce moment pour le
patron de canal+
mais je qui a eu qu'a eu l'élégance de
nous faire travailler de de venir me
chercher parce pour ce que je sais faire
mais sinon je me suis dit mais comment
je vais faire pour nourrir mes filles
pour les loger pour payer des études de
ma fille au canada ge qui comment je
vais faire
vous n'avez rien et tout s'est écroulé
tous et des couleurs et tout s'est
écroulé et je vous le dis ça peut
arriver ça tout ça peut arriver au les
gens qui sont autour de cette table vous
pourrez d'autres personnes vous parlez
vous parler aujourd'hui à cause de ce
tweet de mort sociale
septièmement socialement oui c'est une
mort sociale c'est un crime social on
utilise les réseaux sociaux on utilise
twitter facebook et puis le tribunal il
est là - vous savez mon procès il s'est
fait sur twitter que j'ai été condamné
en 72 heures et j'ai été condamné comme
un harceleur sexuel de travail alors
pour sandra minérale a eu un vrai procès
elle a eu un procès le 29 mai avec des
avocats avec des juges et cesser ces
juges qui l'ont condamné et en plus et
c'est normal elles peuvent faire appel
vous savez sur twitter je rappelle
n'existe pas alors à la fapel ce qu'elle
est condamnée à quinze mille euros de
dommages-intérêts 5000 euros pour le
remboursement des frais de procédure à
retirer le tweet
si je il a publié des communiqués
judiciaire sur son compte twitter et
dans deux organes de presse elle va
faire appel sandra muller elle a fait
une vidéo vous allez nous dire ce que
vous en pensez vous regardez décision
est lourde elle est punitif
elle est décevante elle est
incompréhensible pour moi cette décision
n'enlève rien du tout elle n'enlève rien
au fait que la parole des femmes s'est
libérée
que vous devez continuer à parler que
vous devez continuer à dénoncer les
agissements répréhensibles quels qu'ils
soient
la peur ne doivent pas gagner la plante
ne doit pas changer de camp je
continuerai donc de me battre sur ces
questions chaque jour alors vous avez dû
déménager oui vous avez perdu ou gagné
des amis mais le plus dur pour vous vous
dites c'est que vos enfants et vos
petits enfants
voyez votre nom associé au mot porc
c'est qu'il tapait sur internet votre
mot votre nom et voyez le mot porc
associé à votre nom et ça ça a été
extrêmement difficile
oui c'est aussi pour ça que je me suis
battue parce que vous savez même ma
fille la plus jeune elle avait 12 ans à
l'époque des faits je fais toujours pas
parlé je vais le faire là demain parce
que je cherchais à la protéger il ya
beaucoup d'ados qui vous regarde bien
sûr on sait tous que quand il ya une
histoire comme ça on se moque de la
personne et c'est pour ça qu'on exemple
j'ai très peu parlé pendant deux ans
parce que je voulais pas qu'on voit à la
télé ailleurs et parce que je voulais
protéger ma fille qui ont du coup repas
dans la cour de récré après en disant à
ton père sémalens stentor ton père ses
balances ton port et je suis très fier
de ça parce que j'ai protégé ma fille et
maintenant je veux aussi que mes
petits-enfants mes arrières
petits-enfants dont 50 ans quand je
serai plus là mais quand il t'apprend
mon nom y verront ils verront que j'ai
gagné un procès je ne suis pas un port
et que je ne venais pas été condamné
pour harcèlement sexuel dans le boulot
je vous donnais une anecdote quand
j'étais equidia mon premier geste
nationale et la chaîne du consacrée au
cheval n'était pas trop que j'ai dirigés
14 ans mon premier ma première décision
c'était de virer un journaliste pour
harcèlement sexuel il harcelait une
animatrice qui a témoigné dans le cadre
du procès pour raconter cette histoire
et j'ai toujours été pour et c'est ce
que je comprends pas dans le message je
suis pour cette libération de la parole
elekta pour dire des mensonges pas se
produire n'importe que ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes briser ce que vous pensez que
vous allez pouvoir revenir et
retravaillé comme avant où pensez que
c'est mine de rien malgré à cause de ça
c'est terminé bon
j'espère que cette décision va lever une
barrière pour pour des gens que je
comprends un con imaginez quelqu'un qui
veut m'embaucher
la réaction qu'il va y avoir des femmes
dans la société ou des chaussures
aujourd'hui c'est clair la décision elle
est limpide
je ne suis pas un harceleur sexuel au
boulot géraldine non alors effectivement
que vous ayez été lourd sans doute
vulgaire sans doute alcoolisées vous
l'avez dit vous avez mais bon au delà de
ça moi je pense qu'effectivement ça
libère la parole des femmes
mais salah lieberman et tsahal alibert
pourquoi faire en fait
est ce que vraiment depuis le hashtag
balance t'emporte il y a eu moins de
féminicide donc absolument pas depuis
cinq ans le nombre de féminicide et aux
mêmes au même niveau au même niveau
immonde atroce énorme donc moi j'ai du
mal avec ce hashtag parce que depuis le
début et ça j'ai toujours dit je trouve
qu'en fait elle stigmatise les hommes et
on ne fera jamais rien à mon avis contre
les hommes sans les hommes on a besoin
d'eux et oui il ya des hommes qui drague
et qui sont lourds faut louer c'est pas
pour autant que vous l'avez bâillonner
que vous l'avez poursuivi dans les
couloirs d'un hôtel à cames et que vous
avez été violent donc il faut faire
vraiment attention parce que je pense
qu'on fera jamais rien sans vous sans
les hommes et je pense que ça on est
dans un monde un peu bizarre un peu
puritains et un peu malade ou
aujourd'hui on va demander la permission
à marlène schiappa pour aller draguer
une famille si toutes les sauces à la
casse mais parce que elle elle a nommé
lui absolument stigmatiser les hommes
arnaud chabat jamais désole a dépendu
voilà je la connais la cedeao l'a jamais
vous avez vous avez un problème avec
elle j'ai un problème à la stigmatiser
les hommes et ce à un vrai problème en
mai non mais j'y rallye dès qu'on parle
de ça c'est vrai que vous avez vous avez
alors moi je vais lancer le constat
[ __ ] alors que dia aussi des
cochonnes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais les aléas à la crau avec cette
histoire est même question à jean michel
larqué tiens bon de ces voix là les
attendait rigueur est ce que cette
affaire là est ce que ce hashtag balance
non-ports lancé par sandra muller est ce
que mine de rien jean mi vous faites
très attention aujourd'hui à comment
vous draguer est-ce que vous avez changé
d'attitude est ce que vous avez peur dit
la vérité pas changé l'habitude parce
que j'étais par jacky leymat d'actes
répréhensibles alors oui mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que suite à la sphère des
rébellions et je suis très content que
son honneur soit rétabli je trouve ça
dommage commettre deux ans pour être un
honneur
après c'est l'effet était simple on
aurait pu faire beaucoup plus tôt il
n'aurait pas eu des démarches peut-être
que ça use voilà mais c'est vrai que moi
je me suis dit mais s'il ya une ex
quelque 65 qui m'en veut parce que je le
trouve que je les quitte est trop
brutalement là pour toi et qui veut se
venger en deux secondes sur internet
elle me ruine en deux secondes sur son
travail parce que peu le principe de
précaution va faire que vous avez
m'écarter en attendant que la preuve
soit fait qu'ils aient rien ça c'est que
je ne sais pas comment le faire mais ça
ne l'est malheureusement le mal sera
déjà fait donc j'ai serré les seize
fruits pendant deux ans enfin un peu
moins maintenant sur le mouvement s'est
un peu s'est un peu tassé un peu mais
c'est vrai que ne n'y mets pas tomber si
vous comprenez vous que certaines femmes
moi je dis les voilà je me dis aussi
parce que moi j'ai plein de copines
aussi qui me que certains mecs quand ils
sont alcoolisés ratissant soir il se
peuvent être hyper loup et bien sûr on
peut se sentir les jeunes femmes des
phases les passes les femmes peuvent se
sentir oppressé
elles peuvent se sentir en danger ça va
célébrer non mais je sais ce que ça non
mais bien sûr mais là c'était pas du
harcèlement l'air sans nom mais c'était
là c'était une seule fois bien sûr que
lorsque moi je trouve que par exemple
cette décision ça permet justement
d'aider à libérer la parole lorsqu on
punit celle qui monte et ça c'est très
important la plupart sont peut être
raison quand il ya une qui ment il faut
les punir
alors eric brion parce qu'on va on va
clôturer eric vous aujourd'hui est ce
que vous êtes vous dit je vois là je
peux me retourner j'essaye d'être un
homme heureux aujourd'hui avec la suite
pour la suite
c'est d'abord de de préparer l'appel
puisqu'il va y avoir quand même une
suite
et puis ça va être de reprendre
sereinement mais recherche de travail de
pouvoir dire 'voilà ce procès je vais
gagner et c'est une décision c'est une
décision france édition de la vraie
justice
vous lui en voulez à sandra müller en
fait jurer là pour vous il décale à
briser votre vie oui mais ça a duré deux
ans au début j en ai voulu parce que
elle s'est beaucoup acharné après le
tweet je vais vous donner un exemple il
ya une journaliste de l'ops qui
s'appelle marie vaton qui a écrit un
papier et qui a écrit ce qui était quand
même facile à vérifier que j'étais le
patron de sandra muller à l'époque des
faits sandra muller retweete se hait les
journalistes elle retweete ce message
alors vous aideront à cet article elle
aurait pu étonner et et dire je n'étais
pas je ne travaillais pas avec eric
brion d'accord donc en fait ce que
j'explique c'est que ni tous ces sorties
d'une d'une enquête journalistique très
forte pendant des mois qui aboutit à la
ferme einstein et au fait qu' on est des
preuves ce qui s'est passé avec balances
ton port et c'est ça que je reproche est
qu il ya eu un tweet et après la essayer
de reconstruire l'histoire à l'envers
contre évitez le premier league voilà on
a eu beaucoup
il y en a pas eu beaucoup et voilà donc
aujourd'hui le procès va être elle a
fait appel donc son annulaire donc on va
suivre la décision de l'appel
merci à tous on voulait absolument
montrer tes moyens je sais que dans tpm
paix voilà vous montrerez gad elmaleh du
maroc
on rigole voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on a
aussi envie de parler de sujets aussi un
petit peu plus sérieux et vous montrer
voilà ce qui se passe parce que c'était
vraiment l'actualité du jour on a
tellement parlé de ce mouvement balances
ton port